and tonight a major developing story
after the fbi raided the home of project
veritas ceo and founder james o'keefe
along with other project veritas
journalists as part of an investigation
into a diary believed to have been
written by joe biden's daughter ashley
now according to o'keefe within an hour
of the first raid last week the new york
times reached out for comment now how
did the times know about the search
warrant so quickly i don't know it's
just one of many unanswered questions
kind of sounds like that pre-dawn raid
on roger stone fake news cnn cameras
just happened to be there uh at five
o'clock in the morning anyway here to
explain more his first interview he is
the ceo and founder of project veritas
james o'keefe along with his attorney
paul uh cali is with us uh welcome both
of you james i think it's important to
establish
other media
and i'm not comparing you to other media
but other media use undercover cameras
and have for many many years like even
60 minutes and uh nbc's to catch a
predator right that this this is not a
new form of journalism you acknowledge
that
well sean on saturday morning
i acknowledged that but i woke up to a
pre-dawn raid
banging on my door
i went to the door to answer the door
and there were 10 fbi agents with a
battering ram
white blinding lights they turned me
around handcuffed me and threw me
against the hallway
i was partially clothed in front of my
neighbors they confiscated my phone they
raided my apartment
on my phone where many of my reporters
notes a lot of my sources unrelated to
this story
and a lot of confidential donor
information to our news organization
sean so
i've heard the phrase the process
is the punishment i didn't really
understand
what that meant
until this weekend and and sean i
wouldn't wish this on any journalist
let me let me go into the issue
like anybody
that works in any form of of journalism
or in the press in any capacity whether
you're a talk show host like me or doing
what you do or doing what anybody else
does
in the course of doing your work you
have sources correct you have
whistleblowers you have people giving
you tips all the time to what extent can
you tell us the context under which
you were given this diary you i assume
you did not take the diary yourself did
you know is that correct
that's correct i'll speak to that sean
if i can um
an anonymous source contacted project
veritas and indicated the source had in
its lawful possession a copy of the
diary that the source said belonged to
ashley biden
project veritas had no prior contact
with the source source had a lawyer
the lawyer engaged in negotiations with
veritas's in-house counsel in the
resulting written agreement like so many
news organizations do veritas the the
the source again affirmed that it had
lawful possession of the source material
in exchange for that
veritas agreed to pay money for the
right
to publish
the material as you know sean
veritas never did it killed the story on
the newsroom floor it went a step
further and it turned the material into
local law enforcement
the actions of president biden's
department of justice in this case
are unprecedented because there's let me
let me go into this court precedent
james i've known you for a long time you
had no direct knowledge that
what the source was giving you was could
in any way have been stolen
you at you were not able to corroborate
the authenticity of the diary and you
never ran it at what point then did you
go to law enforcement on your own
unsolicited and tell them that you had
this in your possession and it might be
somebody else's
well sean i mean we you know we get
sources come to us all the time we have
thousands of sources come to project
veritas the routine nature of journalism
to
to be shown information from a variety
of sources
but this is an attack
on the first amendment
by the department of justice uh we we
didn't we didn't uh publish the story we
uh we couldn't authenticate the story so
our journalists looked into it we
couldn't we did not publish a story
because we could not authenticate it
which by the way if you can't
authenticate it then you did the right
thing at what point did you feel a need
to bring this to law enforcement at what
point in the process did that happen
after the decision was made
to kill the story and not run it i gotta
add one thing if i could sean you use
the s word it's really important to
understand not to buy the premise that
the diary is stolen
i nope nobody well that was my next
question if that's the case
i i have been reading all over
the internet everywhere in between that
she claims it was stolen but other
people claim it might have been left in
a
former place of residence of hers do we
have an answer to that question
we do but you know i think people might
look at me and say
that i'm crazy for talking about the
facts at the level i have already and so
i'm going to respectfully say that's
going to come out it's going to be
awfully favorable to james and awfully
favorable to his news organization well
i think it's awfully interesting that
james is the one that brought it to law
enforcement's attention let me ask this
question
what is the alleged crime
that they have here
i don't know
this was i didn't tell you turned in a
year ago
well
the search warrant
has
missed prison of a felony
accessory after the fact and
transporting material across state lines
as the basis for raiding the home of a
journalist and seizing his work papers
and journalist notes
i would assume both of you are pretty
familiar with daniel ellsberg and the
pentagon papers case and the new york
times obtaining uh stolen top secret
documents that they were publishing they
actually set a precedent in this u.s
supreme court in a 6-3 decision that
said they had the right to publish it
even though that was stolen material
do you see something right to publish
the right
it's it's entirely similar there's no
exception to mr o'keefe and project
veritas the right to take the material
knowing it was stolen the right to seek
comment the right to investigate and
ultimately the right to publish this is
outrageous and unprecedented and
journalized everywhere on each one if
you went to authorities a year ago if
i'm understanding you correctly why did
this come up now
james
listen um james go ahead i'm sorry sean
i don't know the answer to that
sean but this is um
they've crossed the bridge here
uh of if they can do this to me
um these are about certain principles
that are so fundamental our first
amendment in this country i i'm calling
upon all journalists to take a stand
against this a source comes to us with
information i don't even decide to
publish it if they can do this to me if
they can do this to this journalist and
raid my home and take my reporter notes
they'll do it to any journalist
this is about something very fundamental
in this country i don't know what
direction this country is going in
but but but journalists everywhere have
to rise up
because we broke no laws here they could
do it to me they'll do it to anybody so
when they came to your house and this
pre-dawn raid and they threw handcuffs
on you and pulled you out of your house
and ten agents go inside
um
were you just when they i assumed they
took items out of your house and office
as i understand it uh at that point did
they just take the handcuffs off and say
see you later
they spent uh about
over two hours in my uh my apartment and
they confiscated two of my iphones and
again
these phones contained
a lot of source information and reporter
notes on them
these are serious first amendment issues
uh and and donor information to our news
foundation so yeah it's it's troubling
um and uh i
i asked to speak with my attorney a few
times they allowed me to do that but uh
i i was kind of in a state of
shock frankly
i i can't believe this is happening well
let me let me go back i'm trying to
understand this so a year prior
you go to law enforcement on your own
that you have a source gives you
information you don't know where it came
from you try to corroborate it you're
unable to do so issues arise as to where
where this might have come from you on
your own a year prior go to law
enforcement did you hand over to them at
the time
this this diary
and did you have any indication where
the diary came from
james came from the source sean as i
said
the source gave us the information and
and uh we didn't we didn't know if it
was stolen or not we don't know that
i would assume that journalists
throughout the 20th century have been
journalists throughout the 20th century
have been given information
you know the washington post and the new
york times are given information inside
all manner of institutions and they're
protected by the supreme court of the
united states to publish that
information that a source gives to them
so there's no distinction between
did they ask you for the name of the
source are you going to protect that
source
well insofar as they have my reporters
notes on the phone they confiscated from
the pre-dawn raid
they have access to the contents of my
iphone which is deeply troubling and
should outrage the aclu and any other
journalist in the united states
they haven't had james they don't care
about the contents from my phone
believe me if if you send them a letter
go ahead
go ahead paul sorry i sent him a little
last word i let him i sent him a letter
i sent him a letter i let him know that
i represent james
and
the the in the normal course the
material on the phone that they're
entitled to have
uh would have been produced promptly um
it's the other material on there uh that
is deeply troubling this is the first
amendment it's an assault
on a scale of one to ten how damaging if
this turned out to be true you haven't
been able to authenticate it if it
turned out to be true
how damaging would this be
to the president and his family
james look you know the answer to that
well i mean i think i think i
again i i couldn't authenticate the
source material i had a newsroom at the
time we were looking through it
for a little while we couldn't
authenticate it so i decided not to run
it and i'm trying to figure out what
more we could have done as journalists
what what
what more could i have done but not run
the story and hand it over to law
enforcement i don't know what more we
could have done and and so we decided
not to publish the story so
what what on earth
what what
what action could we have taken as
reporters
beyond the action that we've taken to be
shown a great question
and why did it take a year
um all right we're going to continue to
follow the story james o'keefe thank you
paul thank you for being with us hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else